Are you having cravings like that?
No, I have more aversions.
Like I don't like chicken anymore.
That weirds me out.
[Conan] Right.
Wine.
I mean you can't drink, and you shouldn't drink.
(laughter)
I keep trying to drink a lot of wine,
I just don't like it!
But now at my eighth month they're like,
"Oh, you can have a sip, or a cup," whatever.
And I tasted my husband's the other other day
and I was like, "Bleh! What is that?"
[Conan] Right.
Which is horrible. Coffee. I love coffee.
I hate coffee. I don't like the smell of it.
Do you like fast food?
Are there any fast foods you get cravings for?
Yeah, Wendy's.
Wendy's?
Yeah. Yeah. I love.
Not Arby's?
No.
(laughter)
Oh, you see, he just kicked. Do you want to feel it?
He just kicked?
Yeah. He liked your joke I think.
Wow.
He got scared at the notion of Arby's.
Yeah, I know.
(laughter)
No, I eat. Okay, you can let go.
Oh.
(laughter)
I eat Wendy's all the time.
That was so tastefully done.
It's like you were taking a spider off.
(laughter)
So you used to work at Wendy's, right?
I used to work at Wendy's, yeah.
And it's so funny because I put french fries in my Frostie.
Like I eat my Frosty with french fries. Right?
(cheering)
And so I was doing it the other day
and my girlfriend's like, "Pregnancy?"
And I'm like, "No. No. This is me."
This is what you do, yeah.
This is what you should do.
It is what one must do.
Yes.
What one must do.
When you were working at Wendy's,
you were saving up money for a special--
For my quinceañera.
Quinceañera?
Yeah, because my parents didn't want to throw me one
because they're very expensive.
No, no, they're very cheap, my family.
No, it's very expensive and I have three older sisters,
so it's four girls and so my mom was like,
"Your sisters didn't get a quinceañera,
you're not getting a quinceañera."
So I snuck out and I got a job at Wendy's
and never told them.
[Conan] And raised the money for your own quinceañera?
Well, no. Then my teacher busted me
because a teacher came in and she was like, "Eva?"
And I was like, "No."
(laughter)
And then my mom found out I was working.
Like, you know, most kids maybe are doing drugs
and I'm like working.
[Conan] And you're hiding!
And I'm hiding, yeah.
The deep shame a child has when they've worked at Wendy's.
Did you lie about your age too?
Yeah.
You lied about your age?
Yeah, because you can't work until you're 16.
No, you can work if you had a parent permit.
Oh, I see. And you didn't?
Well I faked it.
Oh, nice.
You know we have a picture of you at your quinceañera.
Oh no!
[Conan] Yeah, isn't that beautiful?
(cheering)
It's gorgeous! It looks beautiful!
I do not look beautiful.
You can see I have a mustache in that photo.
I have this thing going on. And then I have that thing.
You did not have this going on.
I did.
[Conan] Put that back, oh my God!
[Man On Left] She does, yeah.
[Eva] Same thing!
(laughter)
This is how I looked at my quinceañera.